-Maya, I actually was
happy to hear
that you're doing
an animated film,
because last time you were
on the show you were sayin
that your kids were begging to
watch "Bridesmaids."
-Yes.
-Which is maybe not
age appropriate.
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughs ]
-Have you finally caved
on that?
Have they gotten to watch some
of your more adult-themed films?
-Just that one.
Just --
My oldest daughter
watched that one.
And she liked it.
I felt a little uncomfortabl
just like when it started,
because I was like,
what am I going to say?
But she's seen all
the embarrassing --
I don't -- other than poopin
in the street,
which I think she already
knew about,
I think she was pretty psyched
But the funny thing is,
you think, like,
oh, they're going to be excited,
but they always get
a little weirded out
because it's their mom,
like, "Hmm..."
-Right.
-"Oh."
-That's interesting, yeah.
Yeah, because especially
because you're --
yeah, you're somebody
completely different,
whereas I think if my kids
watched this show
they'd be like, "Ugh,
it's the same guy I hear
prattling on all the time.
-Yeah.
Yeah, when you think you'r
being cool, you're...
-[ Laughs ]
You, uh -- Will Forte --
Our friend Will Forte is one o
the voices in this movie.
-Yeah.
-Are you guys actually doing
press together, even though yo
can't be together right now?
-We did get to do
a morning together,
which was really lovely.
And I met his puppy, and he go
to see pictures of mine.
He's got a really cute,
cute new little puppy.
And he looks good.
He looks great.
-Now, you -- Will plays
a character with a bowl cu
in the film.
You've known Will long enoug
that there was a time he had it,
and that was as an adult.
-That's correct.
He was a fully grown male
when I met him,
that he sported a bowl cut
-Yeah.
-But we were probably like..
I would say 24, 25, maybe.
-Yeah.
So not okay, right?
-No. But very --
very in character
with Will Forte.
-Yeah.
Because it strikes me as
he either puts a ton of though
into decisions or no thought
-Yeah, no, it was perfectl
on brand.
-Yeah.
-He --
We've known each other
for many years.
We were at the
Groundlings Theatre so, like
you know, we did
a lot of shows together.
We were always --
And he was always --
You'll be surprised by this.
He always did bits backstage
where he would just, like,
walk around nude for no reason
-Yeah.
-Which, you know...
-That tracks with my memor
of working with him.
You play a nanny in the film
-Mm-hmm.
-Were you -- did you -- were you
a baby-sitter back in the day?
And now is it weird to hav
to trust your children
with baby-sitters?
-The whole trust, I don't know
how you feel about this,
but the whole trust with
baby-sitters thing
in the beginning, especially
when you have little ones,
is terrifying.
And what was actually
more terrifying,
living in California,
was if they ever get
in a car with someone else
I'd want to pull all my hair
out, it's so scary.
But you get used to it.
I was, you know, like,
high school, like college days
I did a little baby-sitting.
Nothing --
-I did a little
baby-sitting too.
I now, I think have more fea
about turning my kids over
to baby-sitters remembering what
I was like as a baby-sitter.
Not that I was a bad
baby-sitter,
but I was just a kid.
-No, but we weren't
paying attention.
Thank God we didn't have phones,
because then, like,
things would have burned.
-Right.
Yeah, that's true.
I probably am just by nature
a better --
based on the technological
limitations
of what was available to me,
I was probably a better
baby-sitter.
-Yeah, oh, yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I think I was probably
on the phone with my boyfriend
at one point, and I think
he might have come over.
But, I mean, nothing
too scandalous.
I was such a good kid, it wa
probably pretty boring.
No one ended up with like an
early Linda McCartney haircu
or anything.
-Right, right.
Did you -- were you happy
when you saw
what your character
looked like?
I imagine that must be the mos
fun part about doing animation
-Yeah, it is, actually.
And it also sometimes is kind of
frightening, 'cause you se
elements of your behaviors that,
you know, little mannerism
that you weren't aware of.
But she's nice and freckled.
She's really buoyant
and delicious.
And she's got some --
the hair in this movie is really
amazing actually.
The whole movie looks
incredible.
But all the Willoughbys have
this beautiful magenta yarn hair
that's so incredibly detaile
and gorgeous.
And Nanny's hair is shaped int
this gorgeous big, thick heart
But it really has this, like -
I mean, Kris's movies are --
he's pretty fantastic.
And I knew it would be
really beautiful.
But once you actually finall
get to see it done,
it's so great.
And it's so funny and clever
It's nice to be genuinely prou
of something.
And that you can share
with your kids.
It's a great --
it's a great movie.
-You mentioned hair.
And when we come back, I hav
a lot of questions about -
I want to verify --
I want to confirm the rumo
that you just have loose wig
at your home.
We'll be right back with
more Maya Rudolph.